let's talk about the new album okay fall
out on the 24th of February yeah tell me
about the whole thing I just I've always
produced and wrote songs with other
artists kind of like my entire crew been
doing it almost 20 years now and this is
the first time I sat at the piano and
wrote my own songs and I recorded it in
a hotel room in LA and it was just this
kind of beautiful scene of a lot of my
best friends who are also some of my
favorite singers kind of coming in and
singing these songs that I was writing
at the piano that just so I'm getting
this image that you're at the Chateau
Marmont Inn in LA you're spending what
39 40 nights in the hotel six months
here in six months you're six months in
that bathtub yeah whoa room 39 I hear
room 39 6 months Chateau Marmont and
Lana Del Rey's coming over to sing yeah
like no she's not coming over to sing
she's coming over to have a tea coming
over to like you know talk about his
talk and kind of the beauty of the
record and I think so tell about it tell
us about that song about wait for like
that was like one of the first tunes
that it was before it wasn't gonna be an
album it wasn't gonna be like it was
just right I was writing and had these
kind of people coming in and that was
one of the first ones it was the second
falling apart which is the first single
is the first song I wrote and features
Angela and Brian Wilson and Lana's song
was the second she even references like
the theme of falling apart in her bridge
it's kind of just a male/female back and
forth take throughout the album and she
just kind of fit in she was there she
was at my place cuz we're friends you
know we've developed a real friendship
over the years what's working with Brian
Wilson like how did it change pretty
amazing I mean the reason I was so
insistent on him being on my record is
because I obsessed over his production
and somebody gave me I've always loved
Pet Sounds but somebody gave me like the
Pet Sounds tapes where you could kind of
hear him producing it's real
behind-the-scenes thing that they
repackaged about the Pet Sounds album
and I just became so obsessed with the
way he produces and his ear and how
brilliant he was I just I was kind of I
was so inspired by that sound and was
applying like the harmony stuff to mine
that I just wanted him to hear it more
than anything what song should people
download
falling apart featuring Andrew ayat and
Brian Wilson and there's another really
nice one called to kiss goodbye which
has Charlotte Gainsbourg dev Hines and
Sam fuh singing as well
those two are out right now